okay so we're at the University of
Sydney to experiment with dr. Phil's
dead bird he's a famous scientist this
guy he helped us out back in the 16th
century as a 17th century 70s interest
60s 1600s Thank You Galileo was was
discussing gravity a lot of people of
course thought that different things
fell at different rates but Galileo said
no no no no gravity is the same for all
bodies no matter how heavy or light so
we're gonna prove that right now okay
let's give it a shot yep so so young
Galileo here he's going to lend us a
feather feather is very light but it's
still going to fall at the same
acceleration as this coin made of metal
so you're telling me they're going to
accelerate together towards the ground
that's right and you know I don't
believe you oh how could you I'm a
scientist all right let's do the
experiment let's see what happens yeah
one two three that's actually going
upwards all right so what was happening
there obviously they didn't accelerate
down at the same rate well maybe there's
some other factors going on here what do
you reckon maybe or maybe it's the dead
birds fault maybe it's the dead birds
fault he was blowing up blowing its air
maybe we need to get rid of the air what
do you reckon okay let's get rid of the
air and see what happens as it happens
we've got a vacuum pump here okay so if
we put this feather and this
coin in here seal it up then we can pump
all the air out alright let's do it
so we're sucking all the air out now
coming out of the pipe down the tube out
of here through the air so we're really
getting rid of most of the air so
there'll be no wind resistance as the
feather falls this time it's kind of
like a vacuum cleaner but it really
sucks
all right so let's try it out let's see
if they accelerate with the same right
now all right you ready for this yeah
one two three
Wow they didn't follow the same right